congratulations man it's uh i i think
and i was saying before you came in i
think it's
it's so great because of the way you got
this
was that you did things that you created
your own [ __ ]
and it was like you did it until then
they came around
and go okay hey we like what this guy is
doing but it's just so awesome the way
you started that way
and you didn't wait for them to to give
you something
you built something and then they're
like oh i like what this guy's doing
it's just a great way to do it
thank you man i appreciate that yeah it
was cool it was
uh yeah it's cool i think the coolest
thing about it is um
i got to make the special i wanted to
make you know and
my biggest beat with the industry
originally was like
i didn't like any of the comedy i was
seeing on it so i knew i was like i
could either change the way i do comedy
so i could get on
comedy central or whatever or i could
do find another way i guess to like do
comedy the way i want to do it and uh
i was able to find that and i built up
enough equity to do a deal with you know
the biggest paid streaming service and
um where i was able to do the you know
the show i want to do
it's that the show is [ __ ] wild dude
literally yesterday i can't say the name
but like
the head ep had to take his name off it
why because he's like
you destroy all my friends i have to
hang out with these people
i know these people i know these
politicians
bollywood they're my friends so i can't
have my
name at the front of this and then them
still be my friends
so he's like i love you you know that
person is the guy who got this done
you know what i mean like obviously all
the credit in the world to like my guys
and everything but the same you know
the other day there's certain people
that need to like step in and and move
the gears if you will and like just the
other day i sent him the finals
because i was like i think you should
watch this yeah
i think you should just watch it just so
you know exactly what
you're getting into you know and um
you found out i can't go to china after
this
i can't do it
like there's just things like i'm never
going to china like the great wall
maybe i'll check it out from the
mongolian side or something but
there's just certain places i'm not
gonna be able to go so
i figure like you should just have him
look at it before and then when i say
that he goes
wait how like how crazy is this and i go
just just go
you know check it out and then he looked
at it he just called the next day he's
like
yeah yeah i got it i got to change
something i got to change we're working
a hundred plus hours a week
for a month straight i've never worked
so hard in my entire life it's
unbelievable all the guys
on it never were working harder than i
tried it was unreal
i was so [ __ ] i wasn't hanging out
with my girl ever i'm so stressed by
everything i couldn't even get my dick
hard i was feeling horrible so i'm just
like let me go please her
right and i go down and
i'm just going to town and i'm like this
is this is different it's not the
there's the flavor is not there yeah
yeah and um i just realized oh [ __ ] i
just as a positive
for corona is this what this is and i
just hop
up and i [ __ ] run to the kitchen and
i grab some like dried cherries
nothing an olive nothing and that
was thanksgiving morning oh no
ah i bet it helped you eat better
dude it was unreal i mean it was so
unreal we were making fun of akash
because he was like
we're basically just like dude finally
like an indian gives white people a
virus to ruin their thanksgiving
so did your fiancee just go like okay
we're just both going to have it like if
you have it you're going to be here
i'm going to get it this is the most
this is the most emasculating thing
about all of this
all of our wives or fiances they didn't
get it
really they couldn't get dude literally
one of my boy mark who co-created with
me coughed in his wife's
mouth because he's just like let's get
it over with together let's not worry
about this [ __ ] we might as well go down
nothing my girl didn't get it nothing
wow yeah wow they're gonna have to get
backs
and get all [ __ ] autism down that's
yeah
some people are worried about um good
for you man good for you that you
[ __ ] did this i was really happy
because you hear about guys getting
specials i love how you did this and
i love the fact that when you started
doing this
um the way you've been doing it people
started to know it's just it's really
it's great for the business and it takes
a lot of say away from people i don't
even mean netflix just people in the
business in general who shouldn't have
say
really don't have as much anymore other
than to recognize something that's going
well
and utilize